je veux remercier d'abord tous ceux qui
nous ont fait confiance dans cette
élection et qui ont défendu jusqu'au
bout leur conviction sur l'europe
emmanuel macron a fait un choix lourd de
conséquences en réduisant le débat
européen à une croisade contre marine le
pen plein d'ardeur penser ce qui n'a
abouti qu'à une seule chose faire
progresser les extrêmes il a une lourde
responsabilité
il n'a pas été un rempart contre le
rassemblement national
il a été ce soir l'artisan de leur
progression dans cette campagne tout a
été fait pour la réduire à un duel
rassemblement national contre en marche
nous n'avons pas pu faire entendre notre
voix et ce résultat n'est évidemment pas
à la hauteur des espoirs soulevés dans
cette campagne nous savons bien sûr
depuis 2010 est que la reconstruction
sera longue et exigeante pour retrouver
le chemin de la confiance avec les
français
je veux dire pour autant à tous nos
colistiers à tous ceux qui nous ont
accompagnés dans cette campagne et
surtout à françois-xavier bellamy ma
profonde reconnaissance dans un contexte
difficile
il a montré que la politique n'était pas
vouée à être un désert d'idées il
restera de cette campagne des acquis
faire émerger des nouveaux talents
la nécessité si la droite veut avoir un
avenir de faire cesser les divisions la
certitude que la droite et le centre
peuvent s'unir autour de convictions
fortes
c'est à qui il sera de notre
responsabilité collective de les
protéger et de les faire fructifier
je suis convaincu qu'une majorité de
français partagent les valeurs que nous
portons nous avons trois ans pour leur
proposer une nouvelle voie on ne peut
pas laisser la france dans cette
situation où les français sont pris en
otage entre la déception dans marche et
le chaos du rassemblement national
nous avons trois ans pour faire naître
une alternative qui soit autre chose
qu'un rejet ou un choix par défaut dans
ce vote ce soir il ya eu là
l'air il ya eu de la déception il ya eu
de la tente
nous avons trois ans pour faire naître
de l'espoir
[Applaudissements]